but first up she's a comedian who hosts
the nikki glazer podcast and the hbo max
reality series out this summer f
boy island nikki glazer is over here
[Music]
hello hi how you doing good thing all
right
hilarious show so far thank you so good
i guess so we're still distanced is that
going to change
because you know you look healthy i mean
i i had the vaccine and the disease
i i couldn't give it to you if i wanted
to how was it did you get dude
any loss of smell no uh yes for a couple
of days a lot that's pretty good here in
l.a to have with the homeless issue it's
good if you fart
so listen i wanted to have a comedian
here right now and you're one of my
favorites because
tonight is the eve of when i go back on
tour
i haven't been out there yeah this is uh
i'm uh how long's it been mark it was
february of 2020 it's the last time i've
done stand-up trump was president i have
to write a whole new act i mean
it was it was good i loved it i love it
i can't wait i mean i'm nervous like i
haven't been since i was 23. i know well
that's exciting
right so exciting are you have you been
doing shows i mean i was doing them
during the pandemic when it was when i
convinced myself it was safe enough to
do
never go to these clubs that were you
know half capacity and i
would perform with a mask which is so
hard to do
i would have fans on the stage blowing
the covet back at the audience
i'm just like yeah i really did i had
them and um
but then i quit doing them because i
just felt like the crowds that were
coming out for those shows were
anti-masters who aren't my like the
people that
enjoy me and i feel as comfortable
performing in front of so
now i'm excited to go back out on the
road and everyone feels more comfortable
yeah isn't that sad that there's an
ideological component even to that that
you
so that was not your crowd i just felt
it you know like it
the people that were like rearing and
ready to go and laugh like ready to
laugh in september of last year were
not people like uh we have share a lot
of common but that's why i love the
that's why i love doing the red states
because they are more
ready to laugh and not go um
that's not politically correct and you
are not politically correct
i mean you're the roast lady yeah i mean
that's why i first saw you and fell in
love with you because you are so
hysterical on those roads am i right
so i mean yes
going back out there is so i'm so happy
about it but also it carries stress
because of this age we live in right
yeah so i wanted to ask you about that
because
are you afraid of that do you have
stress about well i want to riff and be
the funniest i can be
but i don't want to get canceled i i was
really scared of getting canceled for a
while and then
uh kovet hit and i moved back home with
my parents for 10 months and i realized
like if i get i've been cancelled like
that's getting canceled so i
if you cancel me it's i lived the life
that i would have lived
had [ __ ] hit the fan and it's not that
bad it was kind of great
but you but you knew it was going to end
you if it was for the rest of your life
back in the day with the star trek
wallpaper uh
i got out of there eventually and yes i
do i don't fear being canceled anymore
because i can't live in that state of
fear because
i just know at my core i'm a good person
and i'm not racist
or i try not to be racist i try my best
to not
hurt people but i just know that so if i
get canceled i'll just i'll be at peace
with myself and oh
i'm accountable i don't mind apologizing
but if you're doing a roast for
i don't if i i don't have a problem
being like
if i see someone get up during my show
because right now i'm doing um i'm doing
like a
i'm working on this like moles
molestation chunk which
is the but it's i can i can do those
jokes because i
wasn't lost so i like don't care but
like i uh
it's like i can talk about that more
freely because i don't have a lot of uh
trauma around it that i remember right
like who knows it could have happened
i'm in therapy now to dig it out let's
find it it would explain a lot
but uh i'm serious but i
but it is weird going there because i
see people sometimes i see people get up
and go you know what i don't want to
hear this because
obviously something i'm saying is
triggering them in a way that's making
them have a panic attack and i
i i think about that and go okay that
one person is uncomfortable but
the information that i'm putting out
there by
talking about it is more important i
think even though i'm joking about it
it's still addressing it and it's
uh talking about how it's a picture
besides me then then why apologize
i will apologize to that person if they
write me and they go listen i went to
your show
wanting to have a good time and i ended
up in the bathroom hyperventilating and
crying
and i would say listen i i'm sorry you
feel that like the sorry you feel that
way but i deeply answer i don't want to
cause it i don't like to offend people
it's really not
fun but okay i don't want to get eaten
by a shark but i go in the ocean
right now i mean if you're gonna watch
you're a known commodity now
if but if a shark bit me i'm not kidding
you bill like if i got attacked by a
shark
and i punched it in the face and they
killed the shark in retelli i would feel
bad i would want to find that shark and
be like i know you were just being you
listen like you were just doing like i'm
sorry i would punch it but i would feel
bad
that it felt bad
you